[Music]
you're listening to inside of you with
michael rosenbaum
this is a very special episode i don't
say that often do i
but i've been alone for months now
months on end
and uh hey there lonely boy
yeah it's been a lonely time and i've
been as you know bitching sometimes
about like ryan got you know but i
understand it's obviously social
distancing so i make fun but kidding
around because i know that ryan can't be
here but today
ryan is back i've come back safely and
this is
merch cheap promotion i brought him back
inside of your mask still available on
the inside of you online store along
with uh
new mugs look at these babies you gotta
just those are pretty i mean i don't
know
right aren't they awesome their new
colors you know and
uh and uh they're available autographed
too oh wow
yeah i want to thank everybody out there
uh for all the the birthday wishes i've
said this before i posted on instagram
and
holy [ __ ] man i a guy this guy felt
loved i honestly i started reading them
i took like a couple hours to read them
and i
i teared up and i was like you know i
get in my head i get in like you know
who really likes who really loves you i
mean you always feel like you're alone
and then you read these these comments
and people took the time and you're like
come on man people some people like you
and it's it's you i think it's important
to take that in and just say hey
this is nice this is good and feel it
and be grateful
and and you know that was nice you just
brought over a gift you brought some rum
i got a kiddie pool out back and you got
me so floaty for drinks and you got me
so you know you know i'm gonna be i'm
gonna be naked in a kiddie pool
uh former movie star tv star michael
rosenbaum
ends up in a kid's mini pool oh geez
oh god wouldn't that be just that's
where we find you i mean by the way that
would be if i'm gonna go that way
my friends would have a field day at the
wake you know they'd be like [ __ ]
rosenbaum you know it sucks that he's
gone but [ __ ] you know
to die in a kiddie pool i mean it
doesn't get worse than that
we always said he was a kid at heart
that's right and his kid heart exploded
in the pool
what are you looking for my drink my
water oh it's right here
yeah uh yeah this is uh one of these
inside you things but that's just for
just
endless merch here certain patrons but
we got a great guest today great great
great great guest
a lot of great guests coming up honestly
there's some some good stuff i got just
uh
a text from someone i've been trying to
get on the show for a long time and um
he's a big comic guy probably the
biggest
one of them again thank you for
listening to all my patrons out there
who support the podcast
uh endless love and uh uh that's the
inside of you
uh on patreon and um the new horror
patron
thank you to everybody on there who's uh
joining us it's a horror club we zoom we
do these things it's uh where have all
the good horror movies gone with john
heater who's napoleon
and myself so that's cool um nothing to
really report
other than uh you know got the online
store
and uh doing the podcast and uh you know
writing a lot
that's what i'm doing what are you doing
out there i i hope uh you're
living the best life you can right now
and doing the best you can and kind of
uh
i don't know [ __ ] it's just brutal but
anyway thanks for supporting the podcast
and make sure you follow us
inside of you at insideepodcast on
instagram and facebook and that yeah
it's
inside of you pod on twitter
and i'm at the michael rosenbaum on
instagram and uh
you know subscribe to all your friends
do all that stuff you know how it is it
really helps the show and write a review
do whatever you want
um and thank you so why don't we do it
right now why don't we get uh get to our
first guest
first well you were you were sort of my
first guest it should uh you know this
could be the second guest you're the uh
uh the preamble is that prologue the
prologue i think it would be the
prologue
let's do this this is this was a great
interview i'm not saying i was so great
but
this was a you know i had his wife on
the show a couple months ago
marina bakrin and i'll tell you
i read a lot about ben mckenzie and it
said he's he's kind of
private shy he doesn't talk a lot and i
got some good stuff here man and i
didn't feel like i was
you know interrogating the guy ryan but
it felt good it felt like
you know he texted me after and said hey
man said some nice things and
he called me a great host whatever man
it's cool but it was fun it was open
he got i think you know he talks about
his anxiety and talks about having
just it was cool so why don't we just
[ __ ] do it let's get inside of ben
mckenzie
it's my point of view you're listening
to inside of you
with michael rosenbaum
[Music]
inside of you with michael rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience
ben why are you in connecticut uh we
rented a house
to get out of the city
months ago and we kind of i'm loving it
over here we're gonna be here at the end
of the month
um i don't know new york was so crazy
for so long
do you like that yeah yeah it's great i
can it's got like um isn't it
told you any of this probably not
because you guys haven't seen each other
since
i like this um yeah we've got uh we've
got uh
60 acres of uh
it's like it's it's gorgeous it's
absolutely gorgeous and kids are loving
it well you you and i have something in
common i saw a uh
above ground pool i just uh
i was so hot not like in a sexy way but
i was just really
just it was it's humid it's 100 degrees
i just needed to dip into something and
so i
ordered online a pool above ground pool
for
i think it was 289 289 it's two feet
deep
it's eight feet long it's five and a
half feet wide
my buddy tom and i tom came over you
know we distance
we're a mask and we built this little
pool and
uh i'll tell you it's one of the best
things i've ever done
it's so refreshing to just uh take a dip
in a
it's pretty much a bath yeah if it's two
feet deep
how do you how do you how does one
physically how do you how do you relax
do you just starfish it out
well guess this is pretty cool i i text
uh
my friends pictures of this uh pool and
so for my birthday
my friend stacy and howe bought me a
millennium falcon raft
that actually is the size of the pool
so i i lie on that thing and i'm telling
you
it feels right i'm not even kidding
around i know it sounds funny and it
looks corny it's definitely not a movie
star pool not that i'm a movie star but
you know you think oh this guy has done
some work and he's in hollywood he's got
to have a nice pool
like i have an above ground 289
pool i'm a grown man well some would say
and
that's that's how it goes uh
congratulations on your birthday by the
way
oh thanks dude you know i felt good you
know it's really weird you know people
say hey you know don't get caught up in
social media don't you know obviously i
have a podcast and i you know you have
to be a little social and all these
things but
i it was overwhelming it was like just
the uh the responses and
i think if you just take i took like an
hour and just read responses and just it
was just so sweet
everybody was just you know it's nice
it's nice to take a minute and go hey
man
you know people like you some some
people like you
i think it's important to just take it
to you know
sit back and say hey man you know
because
i'm very critical of myself are you yes
yeah for sure for sure and i had a
similar experience on my
it's been almost a year my birthday's in
september but yeah just just taking
stock and just uh
just saying hey something's working
because some people like me and that's
nice
usually usually i find no matter how bad
the internet is
it it doesn't people don't actually go
out of their way to criticize you on
your birthday
yeah well happy birthday happy birthday
you
you you [ __ ] art or whatever i mean
some people do
sometimes there's been people yeah well
people in office
people are you know on their birthday
things i mean things do happen i don't
get you know i don't do political stuff
on this
but you know uh yeah look do you get
caught up in that stuff do you
can you read 10 great comments and all
of a sudden someone says
i hate your detective gordon and it just
ruins your day
yeah it used to be i think much more
that way i remember getting really
caught up in that
um when i first
started working which which was
basically the oc which was
you know cuts a long long time ago but i
remember like
oh i'll just i remember the first time
like oh just go to that message board
on the it was at that point it was like
you go to the website for the oc
and there was a message board like and
you and you look at it you're like oh
that person
oh that's so great oh awesome oh this is
so cool and then one person
and i remember getting really bent out
of shape about it
and and that lasting for a while and
then then at some point just going
this is useless why am i wasting all of
this time and energy
and i will never be satisfied because
one person's
criticisms will outweigh you know 100
people's positive
comments so just chuck it and stop
weirdly enough though
social media which obviously didn't
exist back then has taken off
and and is even more of that stuff but i
don't
i don't know why it is i don't have a
lot of people talking
talking junk and if they do my only rule
is just never respond to them never talk
never take the bait of anybody because
they're only going to drag you down you
know
and i will say as hard as that is if you
if you stick to that and you don't
respond then it you forget about it
quickly and then it's just like
you know i mean you just keep moving
like none of that stuff really
registered i mean it never
you know if you think about it you take
away social media you just keep
rewinding rewinding
rewinding all the way back to your first
play or the first time you're on stage
or whatever it was
and it's still that you know one of the
other actors who you think is a good
actor or somebody else and like you know
people talk and we always care we always
wanna
we want people to like us we want people
to think we're good
we want them to validate us and that's
that's where it starts and i think that
especially if you don't have a good
upbringing where it's like hey you're
good enough kid
and you're loved that that can really go
nuts and that's social
media stuff then by the time you get
there you're completely [ __ ]
and i you know yeah so i mean you had a
good upbringing though for the most part
no
yeah yeah i did and it was completely
divorced of any
it wasn't hollywood on any level i grew
up in texas
dad's a lawyer my mom um
was she's now a poet but she
at the time was like running trying to
run some charitable
organizations they were very you know
they were just they just i think they
raised us to write you know relatively
speaking
um certainly wasn't anything where
we've i don't think we felt uh
over praised or under praised i think i
felt you know
sort of like treated like you know as as
long as we were
doing what we were supposed to be doing
broadly speaking we were we were always
loved as long as we were doing
what we were supposed to be doing
broadly speaking we uh we were
encouraged
uh to do it um but yeah i
i you know because i've worked with
obviously
young people who when i was started the
oc i had already gone to college
i was the oldest of the cast members and
i think that was also helpful for me too
because then i had some perspective you
know
right it was like i'd i'd graduate high
school i graduated college
i had struggled in new york for a minute
i'd come to l.a
um you know so i was in my early or
almost even mid-20s by the time the show
started a little old to be playing high
school students or whatever
isn't that the story of tv look at
smallville yeah i mean good lord welling
is playing a high school freshman and uh
jensen's the football coach who's
got a relationship with uh kristin
kroog's character alana lang and it's
just like
hey these guys are grown men really and
beverly hills 90210
that's just kind of the way it is
totally and i mean it does bear
some i think it's worth noting you know
because i think
i do remember having that experience of
like this is pretty weird that we're
making them and it really was the the
men or the boys whatever you want to
call to
call us were were considerably older
than the girls like
adam and i adam brody and i were in our
early 20s i think were a year apart
and misha and rachel were younger
and it was like this is a weird thing
that we're like perpetuating
some weird stereotype of like what
masculinity is supposed to look like and
what
um femininity is supposed to look like
it's very strange i mean how much
younger were they
than you and adam i don't really
remember i mean i remember miesha being
very young like 17 or 18 years old
uh rachel i don't remember i want to say
she's like
maybe four years younger than me or
something maybe she was 20.
i was the only i was the only cast
member who had been to college
i think adam had done a semester or
something it was like i asked her this
i don't want to do this i want to move
to to la and become an actor and he'd
already done like a series and
he he had the most i think he had well
misha had credits
and he had the second most credits and
but i was the only one who'd actually
like gone to college got a degree
and not that that not that la could have
cared
at all about that you know no one cares
about it for your growth though for your
growth that was important
perspective that i had perspective of of
you know
this is cool this is weird it's weird
that we're on a television show that
that you know that you happen to get on
a television show that happened to take
off
and is pushing you out there uh
the marketing campaign has taken over
and is pushing you out a certain way
that's a weird
experience it was helpful for me to have
some perspective to say
ah this is strange it's okay to feel
strange it's okay to like
notice that because i think otherwise
you can get caught up in it and go oh
yeah
it can be some weird you know never
ending quest
for validation or something that like
you know because inevitably however hot
you're burning at the moment you're
never going to stay that hot
right oh yeah you know what i mean the
show lasts for i think that one lasted
a small lesson forever but it was the
last four years you know it's like
it was hot and and and you have to be
able to ride that out
you know you have to be able to like
make sense of your life
when when the lights are not on oh yeah
or you're
gonna make yourself miserable what was
what was small we've actually never
talked about this what was smallville
like
in terms of i'm sure you know we were
lucky we were lucky with all the stuff
because we were filming in vancouver
away from everything social media hadn't
hit yet so
we were like we didn't realize how big
we
were and that was a good thing and um
you know i had done some things but i
wasn't really i wasn't famous
you know oh somebody goes oh you were on
that show zoe dick john
jake and george or something and i'm
like oh yeah or they'd
you know uh think i was on another show
and they sort of recognized but i wasn't
but
and then when that show hit i mean i
stuck out like a sword i'm playing like
lutheran bald so yeah i mean it was
but we were away we were in vancouver
and constantly working and so
when i came back i would notice i would
notice some things like oh this is
and i remember by the way you know i was
i was the oldest one in the cast besides
the the parents so you know out of all
the
the kids i was 26 27 when i got
smallville
and i mean yeah my life changed but
thank god i wasn't tom's age
five years earlier or kristen who was 18
or
because i might have gone off the rails
i just like you know holy [ __ ] i'm
famous and i i would have i mean there
were times when i think i went off the
rails just
in general i didn't have a good head on
my shoulder even though i had
i never did anything really bad i never
gotten i always knew this isn't the
right thing to do i'm not doing that
but you know i still would get in
trouble like in terms of like i would do
you know i did a little drugs probably i
probably like i'm like questioning what
i just said yeah exactly yeah
i did drugs probably right yeah sure did
i do drugs ben
no i did some drugs i'm in urban legend
we did some drugs and i had never done
ecstasy before and everybody was doing
we didn't shoot for a week and
you know i got you know it's like oh my
god oh my god i've never felt this good
before and then i've never felt this
worse in my life the next day so
but i knew like hey i i don't have an
addictive personality like
you know some people in my family and my
friends and so i never had that problem
thankfully if i did i could be dead but
did you
do you think with the because the oc all
of a sudden you're like that mckenzie
right
right right there was yeah there was a
big marketing camp there's a big
marketing campaign behind it and i just
remember
shooting it that summer or or shooting
the pilot in the spring and
the series as soon as they could
possibly build the sets and write the
scripts that summer and the marketing
campaign came on
in like august and they were super smart
they they marketed it
through like malls and summer festivals
and stuff
and got the show on before school had
even started up so when kids were still
like
wrapping up their summer you know and
not like nostalgic you know uh summer's
ending we're gonna go back to school but
we're
starting to hang out together you know
we've taken our family vacations and
we're back like in the towns we
were gonna go to school and and it just
took off like wildfire and it was
it was weird it was weird it was a
strange did you ever look in the mirror
go ahead go ahead well the the the image
that i'll remember and i wish i had it
up but
maybe you guys can find it and put it up
later is
they they took these like um pixelated
headshot thingies like they
they took images that were of us and
then they they totally photoshopped the
living
living [ __ ] out of them and and mine was
you know i was the bad boy and so i had
like the wife beater
and the hoodie on and i had a choker
chain which lasted like an episode or
two which was hilarious
but but the funniest part about it was
so i was like 23 24 years old
and they pixelated uh
uh uh
facial hair they pixelated like they
made me look like i had a
um five o'clock shadow they added facial
hair to you
yeah like pixelated like five o'clock
okay
i could look like george mike i looked
like a like me
combined with george michael and it was
the weirdest thing where i was like
oh i see i can make sense why you would
do that
it's not me it doesn't look like me at
all like as you can tell from me having
shaved this morning like
i still i can grow a beard actually but
like my when i shave i'm like i look
like a baby
and they wanted to toughen you up a
little bit ryan yeah they wanted me to
look edgy
but also metrosexually george michael in
a weird way
right very strange oh sexy oh yeah i had
a great face yeah you know and
let's be honest but did you look in the
mirror where you were you sort of like
when you saw that were you like
did you kind of embrace it like yeah i'm
[ __ ] i'm cool
yeah i thought it was hilarious and you
know
i got a ton of grief from my family
about it which is great like that's
exactly what your family should do is
just like make fun of you
and uh but then yeah for sure i mean
then also like a cute girl would look at
you and you're like yeah sure um
that's that's that's me hi
i'm ben where's your facial hair
um
[Music]
uh it was it was
funny time man that's fine i mean when
we were in i mean i i take your point
about being in vancouver really well
because we were not right we were right
in l.a we were right in the heart of l.a
yeah and i think proudly so right that
was the whole gist of the show
and and and the marketing campaign
behind it and i think that
you know definitely contributed to uh
some weird times man were you going out
were you going out on the weekends are
you going to clubs were you like they're
giving you tables ben mckenzie we got a
table for you in the back we've got some
great news
whatever you wanted to want to
definitely yeah i definitely had that
did do that sometimes but i also hate
spending money like that like i just
can't
i'm like you want me to spend how much
money for a bottle of
booze that cost 50 like you've got to be
kidding me they didn't give that to you
free
come on ben no i that would so that's
the thing is like you would always do
that thing
like well what are we talking about you
know so
i just remember being being the
midwestern or southern or whatever texas
boy me was like
i'm not gonna pop in bottles at club
like
that's not that's not uh it's not
i'll i'll i'll freeload a little bit but
i'm not gonna i'm not gonna
i i do like free things i'm not gonna
lie but did you do you
did you ever have obviously you're
married to one of the most beautiful
women on the planet
inside out by the way if you people
don't know or they look at her like oh
my god she's stunning but when you meet
her she's
unbelievable and you know that because
you're married to her but
did you ever have fans that
you're like i i kind of want to go out
with this fan have you ever gone out
with a fan
um i don't know that you know it's so
interesting it's such an interesting
time in your 20s when
i think no one really knows who they are
we're all trying to like
batch on even outside of the
the the celebrity dumb and and
the entertainment industry like your
average 20 year old or 20 something year
old is trying to figure out who they
are and so you combine you're trying to
figure yourself
out they are
the other person is also trying to
figure themselves out so there's a lot
of like not talking about
those things that then get revealed you
know relatively quick
yeah you're like oh you're actually
you're a fan i didn't realize that that
was the way that okay all right fair
enough like this is this is
i think that that dynamic is not
sustainable right because then it gets
this it
in it's you know it's not
a a it's not a level playing field
you know there are all these um
assumptions that are being made on
behalf of of
you know whoever you might be spending
time with that are not usually borne out
by the truth
uh the main assumption being that you're
cool somehow
like they think you're cool and you're
always i'm not as cool and you're gonna
see that
i'm never as cool as any role i've
played ever
ever i'm not as rich as they are i'm not
as smart as they are
i'm definitely not as cool as they are
but i will say
jason priestley his wife they've been
married forever they have kids
what a relationship she was a fan i
believe
no way i believe she was a fan and they
that fell in love
so it does happen yeah i'm not saying it
couldn't work i
i should i should have been that i'm
just saying it never it never worked for
me it always felt like weird
but i think there's a thin line between
like fandom
and like oh i like i dig what you're
doing i
i like what you're doing i respect what
you're doing and
you know i mean there's not it's not a a
black and white thing necessarily
uh i mean obviously morena huge fan of
my work obviously that's why we're
together
of course by the way
let me jump into that real quick you're
on set when was it was it day one where
i'm just gonna be the voice of ben
mckenzie's mind like there was a show
called inside herman's head where you
could hear all the voices
i loved that show now when you saw
morena the first time
was the inside voice going holy [ __ ] all
right
she's beautiful or did it take sort of
time before you guys
was it very professional was it very i'm
sure it was professional
you're professional but when was the
moment where you're like
huh i can't get her out of my head or
she can't get you out of here
i don't know when that happening exactly
i i do remember the first time i saw her
which was um she
she was cast very quickly in the middle
of the first season
because the construction of the show was
that i was supposed to be with barbara
keane james growing such
a barbara keane all the fanboys out
there like yeah of course we know all
about this
um but it was weird it just didn't quite
it didn't quite work because they'd set
up barbara to be
this uh rich girl who lived
in you know penthouse in gotham city and
but gordon was supposed to be the
everyman
and it just didn't quite have the the
romantic pop
and pop yeah and it was through no fault
of aaron richards playing the character
and they ultimately did what they should
have done which is
turned far right into a villain
and that's where she went and that's
that that tension sort of under
uh underlay their relationship moving
forward but they needed a new a new
object of affection and and a real
romance that could sort of like
underpin the the show from uh from uh uh
a romantic
standpoint so so she was cast i remember
it was like
october yeah i remember what day it was
exactly it was october 22nd
and for reasons that will become clear
soon and
and it was raining it was a miserable
day we were shooting in like some
pretty rough area of the bronx i want to
say raining
cats and dogs we were inside uh
thankfully but
she showed up for uh makeup and hair
tests and and
maybe some camera tests um because she
was going to shoot
the next week for some reason they
needed her that day in order to get
everything right
and i was filming some other stuff and
the basically the
the executive producer inspired she he
told me that she wanted to meet me
and talk to me and he told her that i
wanted to talk to her
anyway i was in my trailer and i got a
knock on the door
and i opened it up and she's standing
there in the rain and normally you would
think like oh romantic like but instead
it was just this
drenched rain she looked like
something was wrong something was
clearly wrong
and i was like uh i mean
other than just her being soaked and i
was like i'll come in
and come in come in and we had a little
small talk but slowly there's something
going on
you know you don't mind me asking like
are you okay and she was like yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah and she did that thing on
marina you know
tough tough marine like she's sort of
like she's stuck she's tough she's tough
yeah i know i'm fine fine fine i'm fine
fine fine you're like what happened like
my mom died or something
like whoa okay no she would no no no i'm
sorry
since her mom was alive and alive and
well yeah you're satisfied
in brazil uh she she goes yeah no it's
just
it's my son's birthday today and i was
like
oh oh my god that you you flew out on
your son's birthday oh my god yeah
they're like they needed me today and
then i was like oh man i'm so sorry
how old is he and i'm thinking i'm like
assuming he's like
of a certain age and even though she's
very young i'm like
she's like he's one i was like
i'm sorry you missed your son's first
birthday because you had to be here why
did you
say that ben but you're rubbing it no no
no i know i know no no not not out
like i can't believe that you know do
that no offense like of course
i mean warner brothers god love you like
seriously you couldn't
let her have a day and she's really
heartbroken by it and she
she she had she went back to uh
she flew out that night to go back to be
with him for the for his party
but it was this like very human moment
it was just a very human moment so
that's how it started was
it didn't nothing started but it started
with
she's a human being i'm a human being
she she is actually in
deep discomfort but sucking it up to do
a job which i thought was like
you know both sort of tragic but also
commendable right like she's
she's she's doing what she has to do to
to
to to do her thing um so yeah that's how
that sounds i don't remember the exact
uh you know ins and outs of the rest of
it
i mean you you had never been married
before no i mean have you lived with
women before
so so not only have you not lived with
women
a woman a woman never been married
so this is all brand new boom you
eventually
move in together you have a k and you
get married i mean this is life
changing how old were you uh let's see i
guess i would have been about 35
i guess 35 years old were you ready for
this or
were you were you thinking were you
trying to act confident going yeah this
is gonna be great
i'm so ready and then at night you're
just having anxiety oh yeah yeah i mean
you know i think i think they're all
different kinds of guys
but there's certainly i don't know if
you can relate to this problem i'm sure
i'm sure not but um you know you get to
us well look you get to a certain age
and you're like dating is super fun when
you're in your 20s
and in your 30s can be cool but it can
also start to be a real drag at a
certain point
kill me now yeah seriously dude come on
yeah go on go on i'm here i'm listening
and i'm absorbing
yeah yeah and and i was definitely in
that category by the time i met her
where i was like
all right uh not
don't really feel like i have a lot of
energy here to like
try and find the one after i mean i was
in l.a for
13 years prior to being in new york and
i found dating in l.a really challenging
um not that i didn't meet some wonderful
women and
and from some great relationships but
difficult climate i felt to date in
um and and new york i was working so
hard it was that first year of the show
and as the lead of the show like i was
shooting every day and so i had no time
to do it
but but but behind that i was definitely
ready
in the sense that i was sick and tired
of not having anyone
to share this stuff with like i was like
you climb a hill and then you climb
another hill and another hill and you
you're you're getting up on these these
higher and higher hills and you're
looking around there's no one to like
hey this is cool i'm on top of look look
at where we get look at where i got to
look at where
like right and there's no one there and
you're like oh this is kind of lonely
actually
um was that my experience anymore no
it's not look it's an amazing thing i
just think you know and by the way
working together
you know uh
have you in your in your past like it's
got to be different i mean do you always
have you dated a lot of actresses or do
you feel like you know this is like it's
nice to date someone who's
actually making money too right
yeah exactly yeah i i i
you know definitely had dated actresses
i dated non-actors
i i think at the time i basically given
up
um you know in terms of like trying to
find someone serious and i just wasn't
really trying very hard
um and i never i think if you had told
me
you know prior to meeting her like oh
you know you should be with an actor i
would have said
i think i probably shouldn't i think
that would probably probably a bad idea
but you know what i mean for all the
reasons that we can go into but most of
them are self-explanatory
you know yeah but but
but with morena i felt like you know
it's someone who stands on her own two
feet who provides herself but is also
not easily threatened is not easily
like you know
there's a lot there's a lot of things
that go into two actors being together
and there's all uh i remember somebody
saying this to me a long time ago
um that two actors careers are never
moving at the same speed in the same
direction at the same time
like we're all our careers are always on
these like crazy rollercoastery things
right
and so then you have two of them and
it's like this you know
and so that you gotta find
if you're gonna do it with somebody else
who's who happens to be
in the same line of work you've got to
find someone who's like self-confident
enough to not get
angry when you're getting too big yeah
or or
take it personally when you get
sensitive about that you know what i
mean like we both have to have
yeah that can't be that's got to be real
difficult because you know
you know you're going to do a new
project and then she's
now she's maybe not working which is by
the way it's back and forth or she's
doing
the movie that just came out with gerard
butler and maybe you're not
so there's this ebb and flow in this
kind of up and down thing
and then well i'm watching the kids i'm
tired
and there's sort of there has to be an
open dialogue and i assume
because i don't know what the [ __ ] i'm
talking about ben because i look at me
i'm 48 for god's sakes and i have no one
i don't even have a [ __ ] engineer in
this room
working with me ryan damn it
you uh you know look man there's days in
which i which i envy your life
um but uh but but but you're right that
there
are there's this constant you know it's
a partnership right
like on a certain level not to be i
don't find that unromantic to call it
that i think that's sort of like part of
like the main thing it becomes as you
get
as you get older is you just we're not
not that we're super old yet but like
even in a few years that we've been
together or married i
you know you just like you
[Music]
you you are constantly in the process of
figuring it out
figuring out day to day how it's going
to go
who's going to take care of the kids
who's going to get
this thing done in our shared life while
also having time for your own thing and
and it's like it's full on you know
college did you write boy
that what's that kyle's done you right
boy
but i look at you ben and you're i say
this to certain guests because i'm like
wow
it just seems like you have your [ __ ]
together do you have you ever dealt with
anxiety or depression or things like
that
ah yeah oh definitely definitely i get
and moreno will attest to it like i get
major anxiety
i i have depression runs in my family
um to a serious degree um
i and and i suffer from it at times i i
i don't i try not to take medication i
don't find medication
like the the the antidepressant super
helpful
you know i'm i'm very wary of them but
yeah you know i think it's very
difficult
to to kind of what you're saying right
is like
the very things that make you
dynamic on screen that make you desirous
of of more jobs and more experiences
where you can do different things with
with sort of your talents
i i mean this in the the generic you not
you specifically
are the thing are the things that that
that also make you
anxiety written and and depressed at
times and
you know what i mean and and it's
impossible to to separate those two
things in
and you question whether you would even
want to if you could right
you could take that part out maybe you
wouldn't
maybe you'd be boring as sin on screen
maybe you would be a really bad actor
that's true what do you do because a lot
of you know my my guests
i think this show's become what it is
because i think um
it's become something else that i didn't
anticipate which was more about you know
talking to you know human beings talking
and and seeing what makes
each other tick but also how we face
adversity
what we do in certain situations and
everybody's different so
what you say you do to help maybe
control your anxiety without as you say
medication might help someone out there
who goes all right i don't want to take
medication what does ben do
maybe i'll try that you know so what is
it you do that maybe
keeps things in check sometimes yeah and
i should say
i have a a a a
fear of of being
i have a fear of being on medication
strong anti-depressant medicine that
does not mean it doesn't work for other
people
without revealing people who they are i
have people very close to me in my life
who are on medication and is wonderful
for them and i think quite frankly they
don't think they could they could
operate without it so
i'm not saying people who for whom it
does
that works should not do it or shouldn't
be open to it you know especially if
they have the right doctors who are
advising them for me it's it's it's a
lot of what you
you do i mean it's it's or what it
sounds like you do is like you know
it's getting i'm most depressed when i'm
sitting
inside on my phone or on the computer
and obviously nowadays it's pretty hard
to uh to not get that way given the news
cycle so
get out get some exercise take a walk um
talk to a friend um you know get out of
your own head man and just get into
two two and i will say
it's hard with kids because kids need
constant attention and constant love and
support but it's also great because kids
snap you out of that pretty quick right
like you can't
you can't exist
selfishly with children you know and
look yourself in the mirror and think
that you're even halfway disapparent
because
you constantly have to like our kids are
young our kids are six and four you have
to like
feed them and you know clothe them and
like play with them and teach them
like you know there's all that stuff so
that has just been super super helpful
julius and francis
yeah julius in france do you do you feel
like if you ever like with your kids go
i just have to do this because i don't
want to
end up someday being called a bad dad
like i'm doing this because i just
as much as i love them i'm doing it
because i don't want to look like a bad
father i feel like i would do that a lot
like
i'm [ __ ] doing this because i don't
want you
20 years going you didn't do that not
only is that like a
like perhaps the majority of parenting
is doing things out of a sense of like
parental guilts or future parental guilt
but but they also know that too
like i feel like at a certain point
early like crazy early on they're like
oh i thought i can
guilt them into doing like my daughter
is so good at it
she's such a little like she knows that
daddy's a sophie and
for her and so she's like the t
you know she's four so she's like going
through a natural progressive
progression in her her development but
which is when basically
a lot of screaming but um and crying but
but
but but it's also like daddy please if i
just get that
that one episode of paw patrol or rescue
writers and like i promise
all few good you know and and at a
certain point you you know
most of the time i just proceed to it
and i actually win but at a certain
point you gotta like draw a line or
she'll just do it endlessly like it'll
never stop
inside of you is supported by better
help online counseling
i i talk about these guys all the time i
talk about therapy on the show
if you need therapy these are your folks
right now guys uh
it's a it's a quick uh call away
um these times are struggling and
everyone's uh
stressed and anxious and you know
depressed and you know
we need to talk to someone better help
offers online licensed professional
counselors who are trained to listen and
help
they specialize in all the areas i just
said plus
many more like relationship conflicts um
loss
trauma securely connect with your
counselor in a safe and private online
environment everything you share is
confidential i would hope so right
just it's so easy i did it you fill out
a questionnaire to help assess
your needs and you get matched with a
counselor in under 48 hours
so if you're stressing out don't think
you're alone you know
you could easily schedule secure video
or phone sessions with your therapist
plus exchange unlimited messages
and if for any reason you're unhappy or
you don't like it and that happens
sometimes you're like i don't like this
particular counselor it's not right for
me
you just uh you get a new one and
there's no charge
you can just request a new counselor
you can get professional help when you
want wherever you are
better help is an affordable option and
our listeners get 10 off your first
month with a discount code
inside how many people ryan over one
million people
one million people are taking charge of
their mental health with the help of an
experienced professional
in fact so many people been using
betterhelp that they are recruiting
additional counselors in all 50 states
get started today at
betterhelp.com inside inside of you is
brought to you by
raycon these earbuds are dope they're
stylish they're cool
i don't hear other people when i'm
wearing them
i like that i mean they sent them to me
free which was awesome
and now i'm like sometimes it takes
someone giving me something and saying
use this [ __ ] can i say [ __ ] on there
why not it's it's passionate
and then when you use my oh my gosh what
have i been doing
everyone needs a great pair of wireless
earbuds but before you go dropping
hundreds of dollars on a pair you need
to check out the wireless earbuds from
raycon
you already know raycon earbuds start at
half the price of any other premium
wireless earbuds in the market and they
sound amazing just as amazing as other
top audio brands that you know
the newest model the everyday e25
earbuds
are the best ones yet with six hours of
play time
seamless bluetooth pairing more bass and
a more compact design
that gives you a nice noise isolating
fit hey ryan
yeah why are raycon's wireless earbuds
so damn comfortable
because they are perfect for conference
calls or binging podcasts
like inside of you with michael
rosenbaum now's the time to get the
latest
and greatest from raycon get 15 off your
order at buy raycon.com
iou that's by raycon dot com
slash iou for 15 off raycon wireless
earbuds
by raycon.com
iou do you guys read lines to each other
or is that weird
yeah we have done yeah for sure is it
weird do you feel like uh it's almost
you're more nervous reading it
to her than you are like on set yeah i'm
not i'm not great with her
and of course she is not phased by it
she's so like practical and level-headed
and you know she'll have an audition
that i'll be helping you with
and i'll hear myself when i say to her
it's so like
no what about this try this what about
here you know and
like stuff that would super offend me if
she was saying it to me
and she's like okay yeah and she just
like sorts it through logically she's
like no i don't agree with that but okay
i actually like that idea all right let
me try it and she does it it's like
already
you know better than it was before and
it was already good and she just so
like takes her ego out of it so easily
and i am i just can't do it i'm like by
the way
she saved she saved me i think you know
when i was directing my little raunchy
comedy back in 2013 or 14 or whatever
and uh and she comes to indiana to do
this little move
700 600 000 comedy she's the lead
with me and she she knows i'm exhausted
i'm directing every scene i'm in every
scene i'm right
and i've never met someone who is just
so
kind and got it and goes i'm here for
you whatever you need
let's go um yeah this is awesome i you
know i saw an interview with you
and you talked about getting the role of
um detective gordon
um and it was what made me think of this
interview
as when i got lex luthor people ask me
the questions like did you watch gene
hackman did you do the research
what did you do and i thought oh this is
kind of like
you know i know that you were playing
him younger though like before right
it's the earlier years
so were you putting a lot of stress on
yourself because you knew the fan base
was so huge and well sure
for sure but that's like such a such a
like
vague pressure to put on yourself like
don't [ __ ] this up how how what's the
specific thing you know what i mean and
so you
you the way i work is you definitely
stress out about it you definitely like
just freak out
and then you go okay well so that's like
that's probably undergirding everything
for like multiple seasons
it's certainly the first season but but
then you go all right well how do i
channel this into something mildly
productive and then you go
it's actually a great scenario and i
will say
my conversations with bruno heller who
created gotham
you know who sort of the way the way
this happened is
the year prior to gotham bruno and i did
a pilot for cbs
which never got picked up um it was me
and mandy moore
actually oh she's so sweet she's awesome
she's a doll
uh and we hit it off bruno and i the
pilot didn't go
but i was under a deal at warner
brothers after that and unbeknownst to
me
vernon was writing gotham and and they
had sold it
and he called me you know the following
like january or february the following
year and was like hey
i wrote this part you know with you in
mind like take a look at it
and i was like that's cool like that's
no one's ever written a part
for me ever or since
[Laughter]
perhaps more telling um but like you
know so i read it and i was like wow
yeah this is you know it was hard to
argue against
how cool the idea is um so much so that
that uh
and i don't want to get ahead of
ourselves you might even do the same
idea again
if you wanted to to do good cop show set
in gotham city
you could do it again even after you've
done gotham um do you know about this
no okay so what was cool about it it was
was
the bruno talked to me about how
in some senses you you sort of are free
of
of doing some
you know commissioner gordon copy
whether you're copying old men or
whoever
because you're just seeing them in a
completely different chapter of their
lives i mean you're seeing rookie police
detective jeff gordon so
he's in his late 20s maybe you know
uh uh even though i was in my mid-30s
people saying
where's his english accent wasn't he
like gary oldman
look now it's funny well what's funny is
that bruno and danny cannon who directed
the pilot was our other
main ep besides um john stephen both
both english like so they both talk
actually like gary and i think danny
even even knows gary and like play
soccer used to play soccer with him um
yeah no i mean it just felt like look
we're doing something completely
different and and quite frankly i mean
as good as gary oldman is and he is
pretty phenomenally talented and
successful you know
what he was doing in the movies is so
different than the role that gordon
needs to play in the series because
gordon in the series is the focus of the
show and needs to play that
you know i in my opinion always felt
like and this is definitely i think what
i think bruno would agree is like he
needed to be a little bit about every
man
needed to have a little bit of that you
know kind of chip on his shoulder
you know young guy in a big bad world
not beating down yet to have somewhere
to go you have an ark
had somewhere to go yeah yeah and
ironically you know
what i loved about it the thing that i
loved about it from a
character journey standpoint is most of
the time in most series you see a
character
succeed and succeed and succeed and like
their arc just think they overcome
obstacles present themselves to keep
overcoming them and overcoming their way
to
you know fulfillment right like you
could argue maybe even like
like um uh you know welling's character
and smallville right like he's
slowly gonna become superman but here
not only is our guy not the kind of
becoming a superhero he's literally just
a flesh and blood man
he as he ascends up the ark of the
police
you know hierarchy the city falls apart
the city like descends into anarchy
and has to like more and more in order
to necessitate batman in order to
necessitate
like what what what we're ending with
which is that there is a batman
so it's like he's going up as everything
else is falling apart which i think is
such a cool
you know kind of in inversion of the
usual circumstances
um so i really dug that and bruno is
you know pretty much a genius and and so
he was he was always smarter than me
about
about sort of contextualizing it and
making me feel like okay cool
well i mean the worst that'll happen is
you know it doesn't the show doesn't
quite work or maybe i'm not as
good as something i'm never as good as i
hope i would be uh
um but but it's not it's not based on
like
my impression of a vague jim gordon you
know what i mean like there's no
yeah i mean i feel the same way if i
would have been like i'm gonna do gene
hackman i'm like
hey clark how's it going and just you
know and by the way gene hackman's my
favorite but
honestly i said just play it real
just be genuine be real have emotions
and once i shave my [ __ ] head which
you didn't have to do
it just that i was like all right i'm
here i'm ready put on a suit
oh look i wear short i'm wearing shorts
sandals and a t-shirt this is how i
dress norma
you put on a suit and two or 300 shoes
and a tie
and give me a mansion and shave my head
i am going to be
different yeah and i needed all that so
but for you
it was like hey i'm ben mckenzie they're
going to do my hair a little bit it's
going to be in a different time
but did you did you feel like day one
you felt like i feel like this guy i
feel like it
i felt like they had all of those things
that you talked about all those
resources were so teed up i mean i
remember
we shot a pilot we were not picked up to
series you know
officially yet but i walked into this
two-story
gcpd set that they built
it was gotta be i forget how much
somebody told me how much it cost but
it's definitely a million dollar set if
not more
and you know to build a million dollar
two to two story set i'd never been on a
two-story set and never been on a set
where you could have multiple open
levels um
and 200 background inside of a set
before and i remember
showing up and thankfully they walked me
through you know i got to see
see it before i had to film there and
going
okay all right got it i know it's gonna
have all the toys behind you like you're
gonna have all the
the settings gonna be there you're gonna
have the clothes you're gonna have the
the manpower so to speak to like support
the fact that you were supposed to be a
leader of men
like jim gordon spoke right later men
now you need to be a leader
now you need to the rest is up to you
that's see that's anxiety that's like
you're sitting there you're looking to
say going yep yep i'm
pretending i'm confident and inside
you're about to [ __ ] your pants and
you're going
yeah yeah i gotta step it up man i gotta
[ __ ] step it up
i remember the first shot of the first
day we were in the set
there were at least a hundred probably
200 background
it was this whole scene or something
some guy some bad guy been
been been pulled in and arrested
and he breaks free of of the officers
that are trying to
slam him in the in the jail cell in the
set
and and i can i appear magically on this
upper deck and like come down and and
disarm
save the day and that's my introduction
right super heroic introduction so it's
great
and we're doing the rehearsals and data
down we finally start rolling and
and i'm literally i basically come down
you know descend
from the rafters you know i wasn't on uh
wires but i
might as well have been um you know
juicy pd
you know i you know unhand him or
whatever and
and i literally remember going my voice
cracked
i almost tripped on the stairs like i
literally went
because my nerves were i was shy my
adrenaline was
out of control and it was super
embarrassing i never pretended it didn't
happen
and danny cannon pretended it didn't
happen to us to his endless credit
and and then the next take you know got
better and better and better but like
no one's immune from that stuff and and
it's okay and
you know you can't let it get in your
head
that's the thing because i immediately
would go to
if something happened like that i
immediately go to i'm looking at video
village in my head
and i'm seeing the producer going dude
you think we cast the right guy [ __ ]
it just i don't know what the word is it
just grows that
and you gotta stop it you just gotta say
stop it you're a [ __ ] you're good
you're remember tim roth in reservoir
dogs when he looks in the mirror and
goes
you're [ __ ] so cool you're so good
they have no [ __ ] idea
you're the you're you know he starts
pumping himself up
dude believe it or not it may it's
cheesy if people see it
but it doesn't mean we don't do it nope
nope i'm [ __ ] good i belong here get
your [ __ ] [ __ ] together
beat the [ __ ] out of this other actor
with words right now it sounds stupid
but i
[ __ ] think it i'm like i'm gonna
[ __ ] destroy it right now i have to
or i could fall apart i'm not and that's
not possible
absolutely right absolutely right and
whatever that is whatever
blend of drives ego narcissism
that gets you there like it's in that
context it's all good all game
yeah i mean at the end of the day like
they're paying
for that they are paying to see you not
if you
if you look afraid on screen [ __ ] done
done uber all right listen this is rapid
questions for my patrons
talk to me it's called [ __ ] talking uh
with my patrons here we go [ __ ] talking
with ben mckenzie
lee anne p which is your favorite
episode that you directed from gotham
uh my my three soups one of my three
soups the
the the one with uh yeah
chris asks what other on-screen project
would you like to do with marina
you know what it's funny we actually
have been thinking about more stuff
because we're in a pandemic so we might
we you know we may do something we'll
see there's nothing to like officially
like talk about yet but we're
we're trying because it because it'd be
fun to do something given that so many
people can't shoot right now it'd be fun
to do something together so we're going
to get an idea ben
for this horror movie listen we take
it's
seven actors we all get tested and
everybody's together for 10 days
and then the crew minimal crew so it's
like 18 people everybody's literally
tested
doesn't go out and then we're there for
10 days filming
and it's it's awesome anyway
i love this idea oh dude it's great it's
uh it's got
i can't i'm not gonna talk about it uh
all right tabitha i'm a huge fan of
southland i have asked many other cast
members this question i always love
hearing different responses i get do you
think the show had more to tell
and should have been saved or do you
think it went out in a blaze of glory at
the right time
you know i think it we always we
definitely could have told more
but that being said we were uh memory
serves we were told in advance that we
were going to be ending and so we got
to to wrap it up to some degree and i
have a belief that no show
shows are not meant to ever die right
like they're all
whatever theoretically smallville could
still be running
because it's built with an engine that
that could that's what makes it a tv
show a good tv show
but i think i'm proud of what we did and
and i'm grateful to tnt for saving us
and i think we went off boys dk
what was your last day on the set of the
oc like you have any fond memories of
that day and how did it compare with
your last day on the set of gotham
you know my last days are hard i
remember my last day on the side of the
oc i remember talking
to you know giving just a few remarks as
as i did my last shot which i think was
the last
shot of the show you know in terms of
filming and
uh just saying that the truth which was
that when i
got hired on the oc i'd been in la for a
year and i didn't have any friends
really
and now i feel like i have you know a
few hundred and i hope that when i see
you know you eat any one of you guys out
on the street when you're into your
childhood we can grab a drink or have a
coffee or
just reminisce because it's been an
amazing time and i remember that
you know getting a little teary and
feeling that and still believing that to
be true
so um that was that was oc gotham was
gotham was different because it changed
my life in different ways i
met marina we we have a family together
we have a
child together um you know so that
that had a whole other connotation to it
but but
similarly uh a wonderful experience
carly t
last few questions you managed to make
the leap from teen stark
quite effortlessly to leading man what
decision did you make at the time to
help this
to help aid this and were there any
projects you turned down on
on the back of the oc fame i remember
there was there were projects that were
literally described as like the oc
in the film and like one or two of those
came my way you know or like
opening shot his guy were his wife peter
and you know
cigarette and i was like probably not
the right move for me right now so
um i would say discretion's the better
part of valor there i think i probably
avoided a few traps but the rest of it
was just
likely the anxiety
and the next gig and next gig like
putting all the energy trying to focus
all that energy into
making sure i wasn't a teen idol who
never worked again
anxiety baby yep anxiety emily asked
what have you been doing to get through
this covid
uh 19 insanity you know wine is a
wonderful thing i love wine
i whine all the time we eat well we cook
uh
we play with our kids uh we don't watch
the news i kind of play
janelle b what's your biggest pet peeve
and what do you think is your uh most
annoying
habit i've got a lot of annoying habits
i defer to miranda on which one is the
most annoying uh
i i i bet biggest pet peeve i don't know
bad grammar i don't like people who use
words incorrectly
i'm a real real pain in the house i'm
glad i
used metastasized earlier how do you
pronounce it metastasize
yeah yeah you almost use that i almost
used it but i think you only use that
word really for like
cancer and things right no anything bad
it's usually in the context of something
negative right like oh then i would have
used it right i just thought i wouldn't
use it
and i don't i shouldn't use big words
anyway braden k
what was it like wow i mean i know this
question i
i read an interview about the motorcycle
and all that stuff we don't get in it
you guys can go look that up but uh
about the motorcycle they made you learn
how to ride a motorcycle that was a
different motorcycle it was too big and
all that [ __ ]
but braden k was what was like working
with al pacino i mean
the first time you acted with him you
have words i mean are you
can you not get it out of your head that
you're acting with al pacino yeah no it
was amazing i mean my body just left
my my soul left my body and was like
peering down over me just going like
this is amazing yeah and i
i was always was always great to me and
and and just
a pro and did you take a picture with
him did you get a picture with him i
don't know if i ever did actually you're
not like that are you i'm like that
you're not like that
i should be i should be i should be
moreno's always be like
[Music]
everybody makes fun of me as you can see
if you ever come to my house you'll see
all the posters autographed
in fact i have right there gary oldman
signed my dracula poster and he signed
it
oh really to michael i have crossed
oceans of time to fight
how did you get that did you run into
him i've met him a couple times and um
through a close friend i can't say it's
someone who's
could be my person who cuts my hair or
something i finally just
and there's a couple times where i you
know i walked in and i
i saw gary's right before me getting his
hair cut and there's nobody in there
so i went and got a pizza and brought a
pizza to gary's like oh you don't have
to do this man
he's just so nice and like so then i got
that sign and he was cool about it
so anyway that's awesome last question
little lisa
who did you have the most fun working
with on gotham besides marina i added
that
that cast was so great i loved working
with robin
taylor who's like the sweetest guy in
the world cory michael smith is just a
one talented mf um i loved working with
him
um cameron monahan's brilliant a
brilliant young actor
he's he's gonna do some great stuff um
yeah it's really hard to pick
and then and then obviously i mean donal
you know donald's my partner on the show
and just like a partner
you know in life in the sense that he
just he's just a good egg man and you
could sit around
he's great stories and and an incredible
life
and and we could talk about anything we
talk about anything and talk about
things for hours and hours and hours and
never feel like we ran out of
conversation so
that's great you should have married him
you know what
i tried just wasn't into it wasn't into
it yeah
yeah dude this has been awesome by the
way you also voice the batman the
year one it was called right you voiced
batman you worked with andrea romano
many many moons ago yes i love andre
she told me i was just talking to her
the other day and she's like you tell
ben mckenzie i don't know if he'll
remember but he was the
the first voice of batman or voice
batman yeah
i absolutely remember her i love her
give her my best are you guys working on
something right now are you doing
something uh are you just we're friends
and she's uh
she's also helping me get some guests
she knows so many people she's oh i'll
get you she is
she is the best she's the best she
really is dude i love this
i can't wait till we actually could hang
out but this was this was
worth it and uh you know i didn't know a
lot about you other than i thought you
were great
a great guy great actor i didn't know
much more about you other than you
always
were really pleasant and cool and i was
like
so it's always a little weird and then
within five within five seconds i'm
completely comfortable and i feel like
you opened up and i read that you know
you're private but i
i really feel like you opened up i
didn't i hope i didn't slam you too hard
but you like
not at all i don't know man and so nice
to talk to you like similarly i i've
always been a fan of your work
and marina speaks highly of you uh and
and talks about making your movie very
fondly and uh
and and and just loves you and and so i
i'm
thank you for having me on and i and i
hope that when this is all over you know
you come by the house for a drink or go
out to dinner and be fun
or make a horror movie who knows or make
a horror hey we're available we'll talk
hey thanks for allowing me to be inside
you buddy i love you i appreciate you
love you too kyle thanks for having me
on
all right that was fun great guest man
that was fun just such a nice guy
i like nice people but he opened up and
that's good ryan you've been doing an
exceptional job
editing the shows thank you truly i mean
you know
i look at them and i'm like it's
professional
they're good interviews they're fun you
hope people stick around you hope people
tell their friends
and you're doing a great job and you
make the show look great so
you know i i couldn't do this without
you or bryce and uh i'm blessed so
thanks dude
no problem yeah i'm going to be doing
some more instagram lives i haven't been
doing them recently but i'm going to do
some and
um trying to recruit some patrons it's a
great community
there's a there's a girl i just throwed
out a woman marissa
and uh her and this other amazing patron
little lisa
they became really close friends from
patreon for being on my patreon it's
like
like i said a community and they're like
best friends now like she's going up to
visit her
and it's just it's just a cool thing and
i see the community and we do these live
youtube uh live youtubes where i i play
some songs and
they recommend they you know they
request certain songs and i either
suck at the songs or but uh
it's a lot of fun it's a lot of fun i
really love patreon i never thought i
it would be this fun so thank you again
for all the support i'm going to read
off the uh
top tier patrons right right quickly
right quickly here we go thank you all
top tier patrons
and to all the patrons in general uh
nancy d
mary b leah s trisha f zera sarah v
you've heard these names ryan because
you haven't heard him countless times
little lisa yukiko
jill e brian h lauren g nico p
barry i angelina g jerry w kevin r emily
k
bobby robert b jason w kristen
k amelia o allison l thomann jess
j raj joshua d emily s
cjp samantha m jennifer n stacy b
carly t rheem jennifer s janelle b tab
of the 272
kimberly e melissa c mike e jake m
marissa
n judith d ramirez beth b chris f sarah
f chad w
leanne p jackie p rodrigo
s rachel reach him right sean i always
mess that up you notice that when you're
yeah i don't know what it is rachen
great it's ray and then chan ray chan
love it rachel ray a maya p megan d
jennifer c maddie s tiffany l
or is that an i straight line those eyes
tiffany
kendrick f ashley e sigourney p tom p
matt w belinda and benjamin are lisa j
and kevin
v those are your top tier patrons who
thank you for all your love and support
um
another great episode next week i hope
you tune in um
keep tuning in man uh you know as long
as you're tuning in i'm
we're doing this [ __ ] you're turning
them out to tune in
turning them out to turn out to turn out
oh dude ryan what a treat it is to have
you here though it's good man
it's weird seeing other faces i will
tell you it is you've been locked up bro
been good i'm gonna keep being good
because we kind of have to
that's for sure another shout out to my
uh good buddy preston christensen
uh i love you buddy you had a birthday
and i had a birthday and i hope you got
all my
my stuff i sent you and and i love the
gifts you and mom and chris sent
and uh i met him at the ronald mcdonald
house and and he's doing well right now
things are in remission and
uh it's an awesome thing i hope it stays
that way it will
and uh foodonfoot.org my good buddy rob
a great organization for uh homeless
and echoes of hope for foster youth and
uh thank you again to all the patrons
who support the podcast uh join if you
like
either peach and where have all the good
horror movies gone and uh inside you
podcast patron and that's a that's about
it so stay healthy stay
safe and um thank you for allowing me
to be inside each and every one of you
you too ryan